Hey everyone, it's Michael Altos from
Orderflows and this is the market recap
for Wednesday, June 7, 2017. Again, I
apologize the room wasn't up today.
There was some uh issues with the web
host for the room and hope to have it
resolved by Thursday um to have the room
up and running. Now, um today's
Wednesday, tomorrow is Thursday and
you've got a lot of stuff in the UK. You
got the general election. Obviously in
the US you've got the um James Comey
testimony and you know the markets were
were kind of quiet actually in the
morning in the US time um that you know
there just a lot of stuff on the table
to digest on Thursday. So, you know,
we'll see what happens with Thursday,
but you know, there was still some
decent trading opportunities in the
markets and you just because, you know,
you have, you know, you're coming into a
period, you know, you know, the market's
going to be volat, you know, it's going
to be quiet before it gets volatile,
right? You know, it can be volatile with
the general election. I don't say it's
going to be volatile because of the
Comey testimony. But, you know, it's
something that, you know, really must
see TV. you know, people really want to
know what what he's got to say. Even
though um you know, he's already
released his statement, but you know,
the way you you turn on the news
channels, they all got the countdown to
James Comey testimony. You know, they're
really making a meal out of it. But um
you know, more people I think are
interested in the NBA finals and the
Comey testimony. But by watching the
news, you'll think it's uh the biggest
thing since the moon landing. Now,
before I get started, brief disclaimer.
This presentation is for educational
andformational purposes only. should not
be considered a solicitation to buy or
sell a futures contract or make any
other type of investment decision.
Futures trading contain statual risk and
is not for every investor. An investor
could potentially lose all or more than
the initial investment. Risk capital is
money that can be lost without
jeopardizing one's financial security or
lifestyle. Only risk capital should be
used for trading. Only those with
sufficient risk capital should consider
trading. Past performance is not
necessarily indicative of future
results. I go through that disclaimer
again, you know, I want to discourage
people that think that um Orderflow is
the missing,
you know, is the the magic lamp that you
just rub and and the genie appears and
grants you your wishes or or something
that turns your um computer into an ATM
machine. No, it takes work. You know,
you got to put in some time and effort
to understand what's happening in the
market before you can make good trading
decisions. It's not a red light, green
light system. The tools I use in this
presentation are the order flows trader
which is the footprint uh volume
footprint chart and the delta scalper
indicator which is an additional
indicator that uh we created for use
with orderflow. So I'm not going to talk
about too many different markets today
but you know the first market I want to
talk about was uh bonds. Um you know
bonds gave some really nice signals this
morning here and this is uh 807. You got
a high ratio with a divergence. Boom. I
tell you ratio with divergence on a high
or a low, trade it. What do it trades
from your high down to your low? It
wasn't the biggest move. We had a very
tight range, but then what happens on
your low? You get another divergence,
another ratio, and then you rally up.
Um, then you come in here, you come up
towards the opening price, got some trap
sellers in there. You can see here this
dogee bar, you can see some very heavy
volume going through around this level
up here. Even in here, you're seeing
some more heavy volume. And you sell off
again back down into the lows, make new
lows. You got a stack selling imbalance
here.
You go lower on this low. You have a
divergence. Now you have here a three
imbalances. They're not stacked in the
purest sense the way you have three
stacked here and one on top of each
other. You got two stacked together and
then you know your regular orderflow
number black number. Then 824. So it's a
multiple imbalance bar. Um you know it's
it's still important, right? Even though
it's not stacked and visually it looks
prettier in the sense that you have a
stacked imbalance, you still have you
know four range bar with five price
levels and you know three of them are
imbalances. To me that's very important.
The market does rally up off that a bit
here. Whoops, here we go. Um so you know
we go up from you know the 19 level all
the way up to the 25 26 level.
the, you know, sticking with the um
sticking with the interest rates. We'll
talk about 5 years really quick since
we're there. And again, it was kind of
similar to the bonds this morning in the
sense that well, very early around
midnight last night. Again, I'm not a
big advocate of saying trading 5 years
or especially 5 years in the middle of
the night because it can move very
slowly and you know, but in the middle
of the night, midnight time somewhere
around there, you had a ratio bounds
low. You had a divergence and you rally
up. You got a nice rally there in the 5
years. Um but then later again, you
know, we test that low. The first time
we traded, we traded some heavy volume.
705 288. Got down here, you've got a
ratio, you got a divergence,
you got delta scalper, you got price
rejector, you got literally everything
in the kitchen sink coming in there
telling you to buy this low. And then
you you rally up from, you know, the 14
area up to the 16 area. Um then you
start selling off. you got ratio ratio,
you know, down into these new lows down
here, you know, where you got the delta
scalper again giving you another buy as
as you start your rally back up again.
Um, going into uh the 1:00 time.
Um, what else?
Give me a sec here. It's fine.
Okay, this is Euro currency really
quick. Now, we have our low here at 537
right after you got the Delta Scalper
giving a buy. do rally up a little bit.
You hit a ratio right up here. You got a
single print. You trade right back down
into the lows. Go sideways. Delta
scalper giving you a sell here. Now,
it's a sell. It's a red bar. I like it,
but
when I'm trading around lows, I'm
looking for reasons to be buying near
the lows rather than sell it that we
could possibly make new lows. Um, I just
think it has more of a capacity for the
market to rally off a low than selling
to new lows and keep going lower. I
mean, that's just me. Um, you know,
people can say, "Oh, you're stupid. You
know what you're talking about?" But
I've been around the markets long enough
to know that, hey, if I get a signal um
to buy off this low, I got a higher
chance of profits that the market's
going to bounce up rather than sell into
new lows. Cuz yeah, you can make new
lows. Like here, yeah, you made new
lows. Great. You made new lows by two
ticks. Did you make new low? Yes, you
did. You made new low two ticks. Big
[__] deal. Then the market turns
around and starts rallying on you. So
again, you know, I'd rather take this
sell signal up here than this sell
signal down here. Even though this one
again doesn't do much before it rallies
back up, but I'm going to at least have
more capacity for a move from here down
to this low rather than from here down
into this low. And hey, yeah, you made
new lows. I was right. Yeah, you made
new lows by two ticks. Who who cares
about that? You know, I said I'd rather
sell this going, you know, way up here
into the low. It's going to give you a
lot more, you know, than than this. But
anyway, um, you know, that's me here.
You got a Delta Scalper. This one didn't
work out.
Um, you don't have a ratio up here.
This is delta surge. This one's sideways
on you. You have a dogee bar with the
delta sculper giving you a buy. Again,
it's a dogey bar. I don't really like to
trade those per se in the sense that,
you know, I find them kind of neutral in
the whole order flow analysis. Um, so
I'm not really keen on taking any sort
of signals based off of that. Um, then
we start rallying.
You get up here. Now, this is
interesting. Okay. So, you have this
um delta scalper giving you a sell here.
Does it go lower? Yeah. Then you get
this hammer um you know, the long wick,
small body, delta surge giving you a
sell actually. But it's a green bar, so
I'm not looking to sell it. But you
know, I like that you have this
imbalance in here. I like when you get
these hammers with the imbalance in the
wick selling imbalance and it turns
around, goes back up. You know, it's
usually a nice little trade. You're able
to get a little something out of it.
In the meantime, it does come back down
on you, though. But again, you know,
here you got the the hammer again. It's
not really a hammer because it's, you
know, it's already on your way back up.
But still, I like these types of bars
with the imbalances in there. Um, and
anyway, so we go start rallying back up.
It's only 9 in the morning at this time,
9:44. You make these new highs. Delta
Scalper giving you a sell. it does
retrace back up kind of close, you know,
does get past this high of this bar
before it makes that move lower that
you're looking for.
Um, then we come down here. Where are we
here? Um,
you know, off that high, you get the
Delta Scoper given a buy. Doesn't work
out. That one stops you out. Delta
Scalper again giving you another buy.
So, again, you know, this is the thing,
right? um with with trading is
you get this signal, you buy and it's a
loser. Okay, then you know it's easy to
get discouraged and say, "Ah, you know,
I'm going to wait. I don't want to take
the next trade. I want to see wait for
it to write itself, so to speak." And
then you miss the next trade, right? And
this is the trade that you want. you
know, it's it was when I when I was on
the floor learning the ARB the hand
signals, you know, it was it was guy,
you know, we were just practicing um you
know, after the floor closed and you
know, I was standing there reading the
hand signals from the the guy, you know,
on the phone and I was relating to the
to the broker in the pit. You know, this
is all play, right? Because this is
practice. And this is how I, you know, I
learned this lesson is, you know, I read
a buy as a sell and I related to the guy
and you know I said buy 100. He's
supposed to sell 100
and he realized that you know I made a
mistake cuz you know I sort of stopped
communicating with him for a second and
what's wrong? I said oh you were
supposed to um sell. I told you to buy.
Says okay I made a mistake. Move on. You
know like you have a loss you move on.
you cover it and you move on. Because if
you
give up, you know, and beat yourself up
like, "Oh, I had a loss." Or, "Oh, I I
made a mistake." And then you say you're
beating yourself up, you're going to
miss the next opportunity, right? I
mean, yeah, I understand, you know, when
your own money's on the line that you
screw up, you know, you you take it to
heart and it does affect you. But
sometimes you sort of got to distance
yourself a little bit from the money in
the sense that, yeah, you had a loss,
but you got to realize, you know, having
bad trades is part of trading. Not every
trade is going to be a winner. And you
know the point that I'm trying to make
in that example is don't beat yourself
up because you had a bad trade or you
made a mistake or you know you misread
it. So yeah. Yeah. Okay. You took this
trade and it lost. Don't sit there a
trading is terrible blah blah blah and
then then ignore the next trade that
comes along because you know yeah you
had a loss here. Okay deal with it and
and put it behind you. Move on and you
know look for the next one. And here it
is, you know, and you get a nice move up
that that takes care of that loss and
and puts more in your pocket. Um, you
know, it's
someone
Bob Bob Ayino people if you guys he's on
CNBC, but we used to work together at
Comr Bank and and he would tell me like
when he has a bad trade or as a losing
trade, he's like, I'm fine with that
because that just means my higher
probability of the next trade being a
winner. You know, I understood what he
was trying to say. I mean, it's it's a
little bit different like saying like
going to casino and betting, you know,
playing roulette, betting on black, you
know, red comes up 10 times in a row,
say, "Well, black has an equal chance of
coming up, you know, black's got to come
up, you know, or something." No, it's
not like that. You know, you still have
an equal chance, you know, the next
trade being a winner, but if if you're
going to knock yourself out, beat
yourself up, so to speak, because you
had this loser, then you're going to
miss the next one. you know, it's it's
you're going to miss out on a lot of
trades, you know, and and I know people
that do that. I know traders, they
stumble with this, you know, they I just
had a loss. Okay, I'm going to wait for
some winners to come back in. No, don't.
You got to be taking the next trade. You
know, I I I know a lot of people say,
"You got three losers in a row, stop
trading." You know what what you should
be doing? You have three losers in a
row, cut your size down to one lot. You
know, assuming you're trading more than
one lot. If you're trading one lot, you
can't I guess you got to stop trading.
But if you're trading, you know, five
lots, go down to one lot. Okay? What you
want to do is get yourself on side with
winning trades again. Um, but again, if
if you're going to take yourself out of
the market, what's going to feel worse?
Having this losing trade, stop trading,
wait for, and then you miss this trade,
you don't take this trade, then it's a
winner. You're going to feel doubly
worse, twice as worse because here you
just you took the trade that was a
loser, then the winner you passed on,
and then it's a winner. So, you lost,
right? It's like that movie Let It Ride,
right? the guy's every bet he makes is a
winner. And then the one time he doesn't
he's not able to make a bet for you know
mitigating circumstances the the bet
that he would have won the horse that he
was going to bet on lost and he's like I
didn't lose. So that's like winning
right? So if you know if you're not
taking the winning trade it's not
winning you know because you missed it.
You you took this dollar loss but then
you didn't take the next trade you know
it's got it's a paper you know assuming
you're just watching it. Yeah. I made
money on the paper, but I didn't make
money in your account. So, I guess what
I'm trying to say is you have a loser,
don't give up right away. You know,
still stick with it, right? As long as
you believe in what you're doing is
right, you know, the winners will come.
They're not going to all come at once,
and not every single trade is going to
be a winner. But imagine, you know,
you're buying it here at 112
uh 38. This area in here, you know, it's
just it's pretty much, you know,
straight up 38 all the way up to, you
know, the 70s before it starts going
sideways. Okay. So, you know, the the
point is, you know, don't beat yourself
up over over a losing trade. You know,
stick around. You know, keep your wits
about you and, you know, look for the
next trading opportunity.
Okay. So, the last market I want to talk
about really quick is NASDAQ. And again,
you know, I talk a lot about trade
setups and, you know, what you should
look for. Again, if there's only one
setup you could take, take a divergence
with a ratio period. That's it. Okay?
And here if you took it, you're in your
high in the NASDAQ 58.882. You're
getting short somewhere around 5880
58.881
and boom, you have a nice, you know, it
just sells sells off very nicely. Again,
where you going to cover it? I don't
know. You know, maybe cover it at 70,
works its way back up,
doesn't hit a low, but it was a swing
low and then you're just getting some,
you know, some signals. Delta scalper
here doesn't work out.
I'm just looking for any other signal
here. It was is all over the place, but
imagine, you know, if you're able to
sell it. Okay, so Oops. So, I showed you
that one delta scalper that didn't work
out. Then it comes back down here, swing
low right off your low of the not swing
low, low of the day, divergence ratio
right after it. So, either the
divergence with the ratio in the bar or
the divergence with the ratio after it.
And here you also have the uh delta
scalper giving a buy signal as well.
Delta surge a bar later. And what does
it do? You get a nice little pop up
here. Does trace back down. But again,
it's nowhere. You know, even here, it's
not even against you. It's still in your
favor, right? So to be getting out here,
it really makes no sense. So, you know,
imagine you're buying it somewhere
around, you know, 60 and a half, 61,
you know, and what's it do? So you you
had a sell signal right off your high of
the day. You got a buy signal right off
your low of the day, you know, at that
time, you know. So it trades all the way
back up, you know, from 61 back up into
the mid70s. Okay, you got Delta surge
giving a sell there, you know. It's
still it's still in the money here. It's
still all this time, you know, it's it's
in the money at some point, you know,
honestly here, if if I see the market
just going like this, it's time to get
out. So, you know, 61 all the way up to
into the mid low7s. So, you know, that
was it. So, I don't want to go on too
much. I'm still getting caught up on
everything. Hopefully, the trading room
will be back up on Thursday. Um, it's
going to be an interesting day with the
markets, I think. And it'll probably be
quiet, though. I mean, quiet in the US
with this Comey testimony. You I I think
it's just more people interested in
seeing what he's got to say and how they
can spin it. I don't think it's going to
really affect the markets that much. And
um but really the UK election I think is
is also going to be uh very important as
well. So thanks for watching this
presentation. To learn more visit my
website orderflows.com.
And I'm still getting caught up on
emails guys. Um Fred I I did see you I
will reply to you so not to worry. So
thanks everyone and see you later.
Bye-bye.